mr. Wilbur needs no introduction but it
gives me great pleasure to introduce
David Wilbur thank you very much tonight
I think I'll just tell you a fuse some
of the film's you so I tell you a few
behind-the-scenes stories of some of the
people I met during my 50 years making
films the friendship tour theory when
one person makes a film is full of
baloney in order to make a film any the
director producer actors writers
cameramen so all the people of these
films are the work of lots of people did
i just happen to lead this parade but
they did most of the word one of the
first film you saw i may there was the
making of the president 1960 based on
theater H whites Pulitzer prize-winning
book I came up with this idea that
nobody had done a television show about
a nonfiction book and a documentary so I
called the famous age and swiftly Lazar
and I said I'd like to buy the TV rights
to make you the president 1960 and won
the Pulitzer Prize was a big bestseller
and I said how much do you want for he
said well mr. Wolper it costs you
$250,000 I said gee mr. Zhou I'm only
making a documentary my budget only is
$20,000 you have a deal he said that's a
true story he would never yeah we had no
other bias a lot of the last one I made
a film I made a film of the 19 72
olympics in munich and I most Olympics
you know before about this 60s we the
olympic official olympic film showed you
what went on in the Olympics but once
television came on the air the that use
of the Olympic film was no more so I had
to come up with another idea so I said
well maybe I ought to get eight or ten
of the greatest directors in the world
each to do a segment of the Olympics as
they see an event through their eyes so
I said well in order to do that I got to
get the greatest director in the world
first and then I'll get all the others
at that time it was a the Italian
director Federico Fellini so i flew to
italy and met with mr. Fellini and told
him I like
do the Olympic film and he can pick any
product you want said I'll meet you
tomorrow david and give you my assam no
he comes to meeting the restaurant he
comes up to me says well I got good news
and bad news for you a bad news is I
can't do your film because I have a
picture to make during the time of the
Olympic Games the good news is I know
why you're here I'm going to let you
tell everybody that you have Fellini and
then when you get all the other
directors I'll drop out at the end and I
got on the phone i was able to get me
Louis form and claude lelouch and all
the great directors of the world I
decided I had an idea for a film that
had sex violence and rape I was a
children's film could you believe that
what was it was a bird film called birds
do it bees do it how all the animals
procreate I made the film and then I had
to bring it to the rating board so when
we went there rainy boarded and they
gave me an x rating I said wait a minute
so I had to fly to New York to attend
122 I said it can't have an x-ray I had
a right to go to the board and give my
explanation so I said why do you give it
an x-ray and one of the gentlemen got up
and said well mr. wampa you have a whole
scene at where you can see the baboon's
penises and all the animals penises I
said yes so well you can't do that i
said well wait a minute unless I'm
missing something last week I took my
kid to the zoo we went to the animal
cages I saw 15 baboons with their
penises and it didn't say X on the thing
so why can't I put it in the film and
then I also had animals like horses and
anything making love it was a serious
film by the way and I told them you know
there is no farm man and a mat boy in
America who hasn't seen how animals
procreate the network's I did a lot of
work with the networks and they are kind
of strange people I'll tell you a few
stories I came in I thought it'd be a
good idea to make a miniseries out of
your laces so I came in to see this
executive and I pitched him as great
miniseries about the great book Ulysses
and he said mr. Walker it's very
interesting what do you think the story
a whole
I said well it held up for 1,500 years I
think it'll make it through one more
television season I did a show called
without warning what it was was like
Orson Welles wore the world we can do a
television show and tell everybody we
open the show on like a regular
television movie and we very serious
about it then it goes to the commercial
the network said well you've got to put
in there that it's not true as people
did your stopping the end of the world
by the way when interrupt for a
commercial and on the other network
they're playing let's make a deal they
didn't think that interrupted I mean it
was the craziest thing you've ever seen
how to sell listen the network's you
know very hard to sell product and I had
a show called welcome back kotter a
comedy show that i want to sell and you
know what this is the head of the
network was out here on the coast and
then he goes back to New York and starts
picking out all the shows that he's
gonna put on the air and it's very hard
to get to see him you know everybody
fights to get to see when they were in
New York so I had an idea so I called up
his secretary I said when's he going
back to New York he said own next
Wednesday said very interesting what
planes he going on he said united
airline so what time he said well with
you nine o'clock flight right what's CC
sitting here for AI said very good I
call the airlines got for B and I had
four hours with this guy to sell him
welcome back kotter
and they brought in it was a hit show I
made a deal with Jacques Cousteau to do
a television series and i went to the
different networks and disgusted with
him but i want to get an advertiser so
dupont that would sponsor some of my
other programs so i went to this
advertising ACB BDN oh and about quarter
to five he got mr. Dooley the head of
dupont buyer on that phone and i gave
him a pitch from quarter 525 15 God who
stole underwater around the world I mean
it was just the best pitch I ever made
and i finished the pitch about 5 15 and
i said them what do you think about it
mr. Dewey I said mr. Dewey and then his
secretary a lot i said what happened to
mr. Dewey oh he left at five o'clock he
always leaves the office at five o'clock
this is at rooster and I said but what
happened is they DuPont bought half the
show and I thought if he would have
heard the rest of the pitch they might
have bought the whole damn show it's
those these are all to restore my grace
kelly i had this idea why don't we do a
tour on grace kelly had left the film
she was now her royal highness monaco so
i went there to see her and said here's
an idea why don't you do a tour Monica
will be good for the for the tourist
business and you know when you haven't
been on television have been seen it you
know in this way she had I met with her
and talk to and Prince Rainier was then
we gave her a big pitch and finally she
said it's a good idea mr. womper okay
I'll do it so being dynamis we didn't
talk money I said well I'll be happy to
give a hundred thousand dollars to your
favorite charity she looked me right in
the face i said mr. womper my favorite
charity is me
later explained to me that nobody ever
offers of money they always want to give
money to her favorite charity now this
is very true Prince renea who's very
sharp leaned in and said do I get scale
mr. Walker I want to tell you about Mary
Pickford you know Mary Pickford is one
of the great silent stars of all time
and I did have showed you a clip from
for money I did a film on this silent
era and in now the studio his own all of
film but in a silent dear the stars made
so much money that they owned all their
own product and mary fichter don't all
our own pictures now she was still alive
and living at Pickfair which is this
giant her home in Los Angeles a male
mansion and it was very popular place to
go all and any congressman president or
world leader who came to Hollywood to
Louis AIDS went to have dinner at her
home so I was going up there I made an
appointment to see to speak to her about
by using some of her footage and I get
to the door as a man with white gloves
just standing at the door like this it
opens the door for my car it opens the
door for me night so it was just a
doorman with white club just that's all
he does all day again I went in to see
Mary Pickford I made a mistake of doing
it at five o'clock in the day because
she had a little problem drinking now
here I am it's my second picture my
knees are shaking i'm in front of Mary
Pickford the greatest star and I tell
her what I want to do and can I you know
I'd like to use some of your footage and
while i'm talking or she started to tell
me a story about her love affair with
Rudolph Valentino and I and she's this
time she was married to two it to
somebody else and all of a sudden I'm
sitting on a chair she gets down on her
knees next to me holding my hand and
telling me this great love story about
Rudolph Valentino and her and all I
could think to myself is a Jewish boy
from the Bronx is sitting in chair and
Mary Pickford's on the ground kissing
his hand nobody would believe it
she did make I did make a deal with him
by the way the reason she had all that
money she was a very tough businesswoman
and she was but she was very nice I did
a lot of films for oh I didn't really
walk in the Chocolate Factory some of
you may know what it is a sort of a cult
picture but I had to this is about Dino
De Laurentiis I had to go over to Europe
to rent a studio space to make the
picture i visited London and Paris and
Spain and then I went to Italy and Dino
De Laurentiis the Italian producer on
the studio there he's trying to sell me
the student who says I'm going to take
you to dinner tonight the David and I
said well I like stings I will take you
to the best steakhouse in Rome but that
it best the greatest so I show up at
this restaurant it's out on the street
of the Icicle tamer he's sitting there
with four starlets to get to me to want
to work in his studio Annie I so I want
to steak medium-rare food comes I cut
the food he says how do you like a
statement or sir what to tell you what
the truth do you know it's a little well
done he reaches over to the plate takes
to stay and whips it into the street
yelling at the way double oven is
distraught over having put do several
Hollywood him over blah blah blah so I
order another steak and it comes up to
me I cut the steak again it's well done
but i'm not going to say a word I guess
I just went and ate it by the way didn't
I didn't make the picture to studio I
did a lot of films for I had a part of
my company we did films for political
figures at cooperations and we did films
two of the film's I did was the for the
Democratic convention of 1964 and the
Republic invention of 1972 64 the lyndon
b johnson was running for president and
72 richard nixon was running for
president now I'd like to tell you the
name of the two films i did for the
present but one I did for lyndon b
johnson which showed that the convention
was called peace and of course you know
what happened to Lyndon Johnson with the
Vietnam War and the film I did for
richard nixon was call changed without
chaos
most chaotic change of the presidency in
history you know everybody this is this
is true story about everybody wants to
be an actress and tries to get filmed
and uses every gimmick they can I was
doing a pic picture on John Gilbert and
Greta Garbo and I needed we needed a
Greta Garbo had to be a beautiful woman
with a Swedish accent finally this
actress comes into the into my office
and she reads for us very good and she
has a wonderful Swedish action and when
she finishes mr. walba have a letter
from Ingmar Bergman the great Swedish
director telling you about me and I read
the letter he says how much she admired
and she was good actress and I said she
was quite good so we hire I noticed when
she left she gotten a cattle a limousine
and drove away so now we make the
picture she's just terrific and every
day she comes to the studio she doesn't
speak to any of the other act is very
mysterious with the Swedish accent gets
into the limo and drives away so at the
end of a picture boys have what they
call a wrap party everybody gets
together and all the actors and we're
all gonna get it and she comes up to me
and says mr. wallpa thank you very much
for putting me in the picture I said
wait a second where's your sweetest
action I don't have a Swedish action I
put that on what about the letter from
Ingmar Bergman oh I wrote that myself
mr. wall she had actually gotten in that
picture using she was fortunately she
was good but what actresses will do
anything to get in the picture Marlon
Brando I did a film with Marlon Brando
he wanted he call me when we were doing
the second routes and said I mr. whoop I
want to play a real villain if you got a
part of me i'll do the I'd even though
it's a TV show i'll do a few whatever
price you offer me is fine so we had a
part of George Lincoln Rockwell ahead of
the Nazis and we would Alex Haley had
interviewed him so I he says I'll take
the pot and work out a deal we worked
out a deal from he comes to the studio
we're starting to shoot any it's a big
scene in James Earl Jones is playing
Alex Haley
and I looked around the stage and this
his script is all over the ceiling on
the wall on the side and the thing is as
a picture of front of with this with
this word lines in it yes papers on the
desk was lines and then he asked James
Earl Jones will put a thing around his
neck what is with his lines on it of
course James said absolutely not he did
the scene i must admit he did it great
but I went up to what I say Marland
don't want to learn your lines he said
well David if I don't run my Lodge it'll
be much fresher because I haven't
rehearsed them I said Marlon Laurence
Olivier's a pretty good actor he knows
his lines you know don't have to give me
any of that he didn't take it very
nicely but I but he you know he is a
great act but he debit no movies I don't
know what's known in mind he devil earns
his lines he believes that whenever he
does a film the words are all over the
roof the sealing the floor every place
you can think of Alex Haley Alex Haley
as you know wrote the book roots what
you didn't know is I was in the Coast
Guard to 20 years of his life and he was
a waiter at the end of his career the
Coast Guard he was a waiter for the
ability of the Coast Guard and one day
the Admiral new we want to be a writer
the album was reading a story in a
magazine it says to miss Dale you know
this is a good story in here mr. Haley
something you should learn how to write
like this and he leaned over to the amur
said sir I wrote that story he had
written that article for the magazine
the Admiral said to mow mr. Haley who
you I'm sending to New York to work in
the public relations departments of the
Coast Guard he went to New York and he
got a job after I got outcoached going
to got a job in Playboy and was given
the assignment to write an article on
Miles Davis the musician he wrote the
article he came back to Playboy and he
delivered the article as a
question-and-answer they said what is
this we you're supposed to write an
article said but I can't do it any
better than a questions and answers so
they published the article and that
became the first question and answer in
Playboy and when playboy has an
interview said playboy interviewer for
about five years it was Alex Haley now
Alex want to do a book about his family
afford for every generation of his
family had passed down some words he
used to sit on the porch and listen to
his hands and they said Kunta Kinte and
a drum and combi bolongo that was passed
down from six generations and he was
determined he's going to find out what
that means he was giving a speech at a
college one day and he mentioned can be
belong to and at the end of the speech
he walked out and it was a gentleman
there and he said mr. Haley I know it
can be belong to means it's a river in
The Gambia and I'm from Gambia alex
haley said your kia food that's true it
is a river in The Gambia Alex decided
he'd go to the gambia and find that
sweat if he could find it now when he
got that he went to the river lakamba
long ago he went to visit the villages
all along the river he went from village
to village the way they keep history in
the villages in Gambia is that a guru
somebody is so well done verbally it
passed it on from generation a story
gets longer and longer as the village
gets against in 2010 the store i'll take
about 4 hours now it takes about two
hours to tell a story and he goes from
village of funny goes to the village of
jus 4a and his command is telling his
story and then this and then Olson he
says and a boy my name of Kunta Kinte
went out to make a drum alex haley's has
stopped his body started to shake you he
starts to cry sobbing you know he
realized that he had found the place of
his birth very few people can find its
slaves and ever find the place of their
birth he took that bit of information
and piece by piece Ebert he put together
his entire life is 497 generation
winding up with the course he being he
being a writer his brother being a
lawyer and his other brother being a a
meteorologist I'd like to tell you final
one story about FDR I did a lot of films
out of FDR documentary he John Steinbeck
the writer got a letter from FDR saying
mr. Stein bag why don't you come to
Washington have dinner at the White
House just you and your wife and me and
Eleanor Roosevelt and we'll have a good
time to talk about literature etc
and this is the letter that Steinbeck
Steinbeck wrote to President Roosevelt
dear mr. president what an honor it is
to be invited to the White House have
dinner alone with you and mrs. roseville
but on March fifteenth on that
particular day it happens to be the day
that they're honoring my high school
English teacher and I have known five
great presidents in my life but only one
grade English teacher John Steinbeck are
we thank you I guess that's why see my
time is up
please story plus many more in the book
out now I like if anybody has any
questions we'd be happy to take him
anyway went over there no question I can
tell some more story but I gotta be a
question yeah there's one right there
you have any other fascinating people
are particularly memorable that's true
Alex Haley and I man and theatre race
why were to it um that's a good question
well I met as you know as you so if I
see you read the book thank you as you
know I because I was a documentary
filmmaker I had an opportunity to meet
most of my life always in the
entertainment films and will you meet
the same people over again actors stars
movie stars actors directors when you do
documentaries you have an opportunity to
meet other people because you're doing
documentaries on real people so I had a
chance to meet a lot of people in my
lifetime I picked those two out because
they stand out in my lifetime I met a
lot of presidents and I had a lot of
people who were famous in it from
scientists i would guess the next most
interesting fellow I met was probably
jock justo justo was very bright when I
went to see him the first time I he he
told me you know what he I told him I'd
like him to go around the world and
taking a boat and he had the Calypso his
famous boat but when I went to see him
it was really a junk the junkie astir
you've ever seen I said well you're
gonna be on television Jacques you got
to do something to that boat
and he as you know we fixed it up and
made it beautiful put television cameras
a helicopter he was a very smart guy
very tough very tough but he was the
probably the most fascinating person I
met outside of the two people I just
mentioned anybody else have anything yes
well I've been in three areas my
favorite documentary that I made was the
making of the president is asking my
favorite film making of the president
1960 which you saw was by Teddy white my
favorite miniseries has to be roots my
favorite movie was probably LA
confidential or Willy Wonka one of the
two and the outdoor of I also did
outdoor events in the one I guess would
be the opening closing ceremonies of the
Olympics here in LA that was a pleasure
to do working in New York was very tough
this is a very honest straight city I
can't say the same thing about New York
yes experience making the pelvis movie
and the John Lennon imagine go toward
that experience making Lennon and Elvis
yes they are neither wish I was a fan of
before I made the films I was a Frank
Sinatra fan but the way like the way I
got to do Lennon when I was in New York
doing the hundredth anniversary of
statue live and I got a call from Yoko
Ono who asked me to she likes yet to see
me I made an appointment to see her
after I finished at Liberty weekend and
she had all this enormous collection of
film on John Lennon John Lennon filmed
everything he did I've never seen more
film on any human being than John Lennon
she asked me to make a film I said well
to tell you the honest I really don't
know anything about John Lennon or the
beetle I really I'm a Frank Sinatra fan
so she tells me well I didn't ask you to
be here cause you're a fan of I asked
you here because you're a documentary
filmmaker and I want to make a
documentary about my my husband and
which that's that's how I got the
opportunity to do that and she had film
on everything I mean this I'm I honestly
that film of the two of them making love
film of them shot at every conceivable
situation is genre but during the
filming I did get to appreciate his
music um what an Elvis Elvis a fryer
somebody who used to work for me and
when i was doing documentaries came to
me and said we ought to do a film i
think we could do a film on Elvis
president can get the rights I said the
same thing I'll yeah I'm not really an
Elvis fan I'm Frank Sinatra but I went
home and told my wife sister you gotta
do it I'm an Elvis fan I gotta do it I
want to see a day and and we did the
film we filmed it down and it Graceland
were the first people allowed into
Graceland and again I must admit that I
saw what have I found out what his voice
was all about was a very interest
interesting story I did that the two
films I still haven't done one on Frank
Sinatra my favorite films that you sold
to the schools would it were any of them
the profiles in courage series the in
the beginning when we saw the film clip
you were selling the film's to the
school's the ones that were bad prints
were any of those the profiles and
courage films
I did profiles encourage based on
Kennedy's book but the film ice the
film's I sold in the early days of
television well there was only about 20
stations open when I was selling em and
they could they needed anything I mean I
saw them really lousy film because the
studio's wouldn't give anything anybody
who had in the film business wouldn't
want didn't want to get near television
the profiles in car no I didn't make
them a friend of Mines father had bought
some travel logs to excel to the schools
they were so bad the school's wouldn't
even buy them and he said why don't you
see if you can sell it to this new thing
called television so we took these
terrible old film and sold them every
station and this father-son friend of
Mines father kept buying more films
right so we kept telling him until we
were quite successfully to buy our own
films but those were pretty bad films
than those that just that was you is
that the answer yeah I the reason I
asked was as a student I love the
profiles in courage films and I've gone
back to my former schools to try to find
out where I could obtain them now and
nobody knows I don't know it there was
one boy the book that John Kennedy wrote
called Profiles in Courage I did a
documentary on one hour but when I was
it was not a serious so somebody must
have done a series called Profiles in
Courage yes sir what are the
distinctions that you made as a producer
that resulted in your success where
others didn't quite encounter the same
success what he's asking how what did i
do in producing it I was the successor
maybe some others weren't all I was very
fortunate three things happen first of
all I started my life as a salesman so I
was able to sell I learned how to sell
from a Salesman I went into a bank so i
began to I worked for one year in a bank
so I began I began to learn about fun at
finance and then I started to produce so
I had the ability to be able to do all
three things because of my background in
those three years I think that helped me
I have to in order to get a film on
sometimes you have to sell
you heard how I got welcome back kotter
on so I had that experience a lot of
producers don't have this selling
experience just a filmmaking part of it
thanks oh yes she want other what was
the young liberal Ronald Reagan like and
also did you know the ratings would be
so high for roots I couldn't hear okay
the young liberal Ronald Reagan I think
you met him in the early 40s ronald
reagan in the early 40s as a liberal and
did you know that the ratings would be
so high for roots i did not meet Reagan
when he was a liberal I met Reagan I did
three events with rake and one I did the
opening ceremony she was president at
that time then he happened to be
president when I did the hundredth
anniversary of the Statue of Liberty and
then he was also a performer at Warner
Brothers and i did a big anniversaire
fifth anniversary of Warner Brothers and
he came back to that empty but I didn't
know him when he was president of the
Screen Actors Guild and a liberal I
guess I mean he wasn't liberal at the
end otha
he wanted to do but couldn't oh yeah if
I failed that you want to hear my
failures right well I'll tell you them
because there are there's a lot of books
I do I decide it would be a great stew
Greg one of the great stories I've ever
read and I is the founding of America
the history of this country how it got
found and the people who found it to
Washington you know there and I put
together a border of people who agreed
with me made up and I these people all
agreed to be on my board I'm talking
about President Ford president clinton
now President President Ford President
Bush Secretary of State Powell some of
the great Thea Mike Wallace some of the
great people and and I put together a
creative committee made up of Steven
Spielberg Martin Scorsese Ron Howard
five of the greatest directives in the
world and what none of the networks were
interesting about the story of America
we had a great outline for a great thing
and with all these people I still
couldn't get a made it to this day then
that works couldn't care less about the
history of the country I've got to tell
you that this is a true story that's to
it started me is they took a poll this
is absolutely true they took we finished
sorry if they look at that faith I took
a pro they took a poll of graduating
seniors of the 15 leading colleges in
America Harvard Yale and they asked him
this question who was the general during
the Revolutionary War and they gave him
three choices ulysses s grant Douglas
MacArthur or Joyce Washington now only
one-third of the graduating college this
is true I mean if you guess that you get
a third right and these are people who
graduating from Harvard Yale Princeton
did not know who the general wasn't a
revolutionary army I mean it's shocking
anyway that's why we started the project
thank you very much for listening